how's it going everybody it's warren
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder where we talk all things marvel
and everything relating to the mcu and
yesterday we got some pretty big
mcu news if you happen to miss it jamie
foxx's electro
from the amazing spider-man 2 with
andrew garfield
is now going to be in tom holland's
spider-man 3
that is going to take place inside of
the mcu so we have some universe jumping
going on here because as everybody knows
andrew garfield's amazing spider-man
does not take place inside of the mcu so
how exactly does jaime fox's electro go
from one universe to
the other well at this point in time
it's really not that hard to believe
that a character from the amazing
spider-man is going to be coming to the
mcu but is he going to be the only
character
or could andrew garfield be coming with
him and could toby maguire eventually
make his way to the mcu as well
well it seems like we do actually have a
lot of evidence that this
is going to happen and a real-life
spider-verse could be formed within
the marvel cinematic universe so i'll
break down everything that points to
this happening in this video but first
if you're new be sure to subscribe so
you don't miss out on any of the latest
mcu news and so you can enter this
week's giveaway for a chance to win
a cyclops funko pop just subscribe like
the video and leave a comment below
so first and foremost if you're going to
have a character that you want to use in
one spider-man film that has already
been used in another
you usually recast in almost every
circumstance you recast
you don't have the same actor play the
same character that is very confusing
unless you want that same character to
be from the same universe and
movie so the fact that jamie foxx is
playing elektra was a pretty big
giveaway that it is going to be the same
electro from the amazing spider-man 2.
now
another very obvious example of
different universes combining for
spider-man is vulture ever since we got
the morbius trailer we have found out
that vulture not only exists within the
marvel cinematic universe but he also
exists in the sp
umc as well and for those of you who may
not know that is the sony picture
universe of marvel characters the same
universe that tom hardy's venom is in
but here's something that's very
interesting about michael keaton's
vulture appearance in the morbius
trailer
now in the morbius trailer it really
does look like adrian tombs most people
would say without a doubt this is the
same vulture from spider-man homecoming
but in the morbius trailer there's also
a picture of spider-man on the wall
on it it says murderer over it now of
course this is a callback to the
post-credits scene of spider-man far
from home where jay jonah jameson and
mysterio make spider-man slash peter
parker out to be a murderer however the
spider-man on the wall
is not actually tom holland's spider-man
it's tobey maguire spider-man from the
sam raimi series
now a lot of people thought that this
could be due to some type of rights
issues between
sony and marvel however if a real-life
spider-verse is coming this could
actually be toby maguire spider-man
instead of tom holland being spider-man
in this universe it's toby maguire but
some of the same
incidents and events could happen to him
in this universe
so what exactly does this mean well
during the time where we had that whole
spider-man scare between
sony and disney which was definitely
very nerve-wracking but when it came to
an end and disney and sony worked out a
deal kevin feige the president of marvel
studios came out and said that
spider-man
our spider-man tom holland was the only
marvel character currently
that had the ability to jump between
universes now obviously he didn't mean
that as in he has magical powers like
doctor strange can open up a portal and
go to a different universe
that's not what he meant so what he
really meant was tom holland spider-man
is going to be interacting with other
characters
from other different universes mainly
sony's universe the sony picture
universe of marvel characters and
the amazing spider-man universe and some
other blatant evidence of this as j
jonah jameson making his appearance in
the mcu
and of course this is not a new ga jonah
jameson this is the same j
jonah jameson from the original
spider-man sam remy trilogy
played by jk simmons again like i said
if it's a new version of a character
simply in a different
film you get another actor but instead
we have the classic jk
simmons j jonah jameson who is now in
the mcu but
coming from the original sam raimi
universe this combined with the sam
raimi spider-man in the morbius trailer
gives us a connection to three different
universes this
is sam raimi's universe connecting with
morbius but also sam raimi's universe
connecting with the marvel cinematic
universe
and to top it all off vulture is in the
morbius trailer as well so the marvel
cinematic universe connects with the sp
umc
so those are three universes that we
already have evidence are intertwining
with each other
and now you take into consideration the
fact that jamie foxx's electro from the
amazing spider-man 2
is going to show up in spider-man 3 in
the mcu means that we have
four different spider-man universes
colliding
and this is the real life spider-verse
now of course this is
insanely cool and we've actually had a
few reports about this in the past which
i'll go over in just a second but right
now the question is
why is this actually going to happen
besides the fact that everybody would
just simply lose their minds but there
does have to be sort of a reason for
andrew garfield spider-man and toby
mcguire spider-man to team up with tom
holland or have a good reason to
at the very least make a cameo now
moving forward it looks like sony and
disney are actually playing very nicely
with each other and some little things
have slipped out here and there like
olivia wilde being hired to direct a new
spider-man movie that's going to be
based off of a woman spider-man
it hasn't yet been confirmed if it's
going to be spider woman or spider gwen
but olivia wilde did make some comments
that lead us to believe
that this movie might actually be a
marvel sony movie and will take place
inside of the mcu
so this would be a fourth piece to this
new live-action spider-verse either
having spider-woman or spider-gwen
and let's also not forget that marvel is
once again working with
sam raimi the director of the original
spider-man trilogy with tobey maguire
a while ago marvel studios hired sam
remy to direct doctor strange in the
multiverse of madness which is very
fitting if the real-life spider-verse is
indeed going to happen because the
multiverse is going to essentially blow
up in doctor strange in the multiverse
of madness
and that leads us to the question when
exactly is all of this going to happen
when are we going to see the live-action
spider-verse well there are two ways
that this could actually happen
one is that marvel studios and sony
could simply do
projects that exist inside of the same
universe having different characters
from different projects cross over into
other projects that they're working on
together this would be pretty cool as it
would be an
ongoing process and we'd see many
characters interact with each other
over essentially years so it wouldn't
just be a one and done type of thing it
would be something that would last for a
while and as mikey sutton from geekosti
has reported recently
a lot of these spider-man spin-off
projects are going to exist in the same
universe
but of course they could also do a
pretty big project and have a real-life
spider-verse movie now this would not be
spider-man 3. there is a possibility for
cameos from andrew garfield and toby
maguire in spider-man 3 but as far as a
huge
movie where the spider-verse is
established that's not going to be
spider-man 3
but we could get a setup for it in
spider-man 3. because you have to keep
in mind from what we know the new deal
between sony and disney is for tom
holland to do one more
solo spider-man film and then another
team-up film now for the team-up film we
all assume that it's going to be an
avengers team-up film
but what if it's not what if it's
actually a spider-man spider-verse film
it's certainly a possibility considering
all the evidence that we have or perhaps
this is something that marvel and sony
are going to want to build up
over time and eventually release to the
public but either way there's just a ton
of evidence that leads us to believe
that toby maguire andrew garfield
and tom holland will eventually be in
the same movie together
especially if you consider the fact that
the wanda vision series looks like it's
going to bend reality in a very
different way
and perhaps it could be the reason why
the multiverse is in madness for doctor
strange too
whatever it may be one thing is for sure
there are so many exciting things coming
to the future
of the mcu so let me know what you would
like to see happen would you like a
real-life spider-verse
movie or would you like to see a bunch
of different movies all exist within the
same universe and characters crossing
over
let me know what you think in the
comments down below don't forget to like
this video and subscribe so you don't
miss out on any of the marvel videos for
live updates you can follow me on
instagram and twitter and as always
thank you all so much for watching
woof
you